[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie you
probably saw the news this morning about
John Krasinski making that big Fantastic
Four announcement he had a big interview
so we'll break it all down it's not even
the first time Marvel has gone after him
for a big MCU character or his wife
Emily Blunt who was also just having a
meeting with Marvel about playing a big
MCU character in an upcoming movie if
you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Marvel videos
I'm leaving that infinity saga box set
giveaway open until Black Widow comes
out all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know what you want
them to do with the new Fantastic Four
Marvel movie so we'll break everything
down top-5 style there been a couple big
Fantastic Four Easter eggs and set up in
recent Marvel movies they'll also be
laying track work and all the upcoming
series and movies - like Doctor Strange
- multiverse of madness the Loki series
the Eternals movie that's happening
later this year so starting with number
5 if you didn't see the news John
Krasinski did a huge Fantastic Four
interview recently talking about
Marvel's new reboot of the characters
now he wanted to be the new Reed
Richards really badly there been some
news outlets saying that he was
campaigning to be Reed Richards a long
time ago I don't remember that I only
remember the John Krasinski Reed
Richards Fantastic Four hype starting
about a year ago when everyone was
getting ramped up for Avengers endgame
but this is some of the stuff he said
during his interview so I'm just quoting
him he's speaking to the interviewer
here saying you're like do you have any
interest in not shattering people's
dreams lapping I would love to be in the
Marvel Universe I love those movies
because they're fun but I also think
they're really well done and certainly a
lot of my friends were in those movies
he's actually friends with a lot of the
real-life MCU actors I have no idea what
Marvel is thinking but if they're
considering me for mr. fantastic
continued to consider me because I would
love it so it just him professing his
love for the Marvel movies in his desire
to actually be Reed Richards making all
the dreams of these fan artists that
keep drawing these John Krasinski Reed
Richards mr. fantastic pictures
seriously can you picture anyone else's
the character after seeing all this
really amazing art of him as mr.
fantastic but not only is he a fan right
now in present day he also has a lot of
history with Marvel Studios and Kevin
Feige as does his wife Emily Blunt who
you probably heard was also meeting with
Marv
separately a little while ago about
playing a big character in an upcoming
movie but I actually think the character
Emily Blunt was meeting Marvel 4 was
actually for someone like Clea in Doctor
Strange 2 so I don't think that she's
gonna wind up playing the new Sue Storm
but she might wind up being in an
upcoming Marvel movie but Marvel went
after both of them separately years ago
for different big Avengers characters so
number 4 the history this is actually
really cool deep cut Easter Egg
if you don't remember way back in the
late 2000s when Marvel phase 1 was just
getting started
Kevin Feige went after John Krasinski
for Steve Rogers Captain America in
Captain America First Avenger this was
early office era Jim Halpert John
Krasinski we all know that didn't wind
up working out and Chris Evans went on
to become an amazing Captain America so
good now you can't picture anyone else
playing that character after avengers
endgame but John Krasinski is friends
with Chris Evans in real life and
obviously there's no hard feelings or
anything like that he was joking about
it recently on a talk show here's the
clip of that that you screen tested for
Captain America that's a goal in my head
I got the part yeah what was that was
that process like because that's a real
question you when you're trying to think
like am I am I one of those superhero
guys or not you know what I want to do
that could I do that so when you had
that test what was it like it was a big
deal for me because I mean first of all
I love those Marvel movies I'm Isle of
super heroes I love imagination so when
they asked me to test they actually
allowed me to put on the suit I was on a
set it was all very interesting I feel
like as I'm talking about this someone
from Marvel's new book and just like
yeah but I remember the the only bummer
of it was I was putting on the suit just
watching I was like this is so amazing
and I got about right to my waist I was
still shirtless feeling pretty good
about myself wasn't 13 hours yet but I
felt pretty good and all of a sudden
Chris Hemsworth walked by his door and
he's like that night and I went I'm good
this is stupid
as you can see he also clearly thinks
Marvel made the right call and casting
Chris Evans but that was early in his
career he's been killing it is a very
action hero version of Jack Ryan lately
but number three the story on emily
Blunt's history with Marvel also dates
to around the same era of Marvel phase 1
when they were getting ready to make
Iron Man 2 Emily Blunt was the first
person they went after for their Black
Widow I know everyone thinks that they
wanted her as Captain Marvel but she
claims that that was never a thing you
sick of these kind of rumors are you
happy about these rumors about Captain
Marvel people keep watch god it's crazy
I have not had a phone call about it
seriously you've not talked tomorrow not
just me in the eye not one whisper of
Captain Marvel has come my way okay
promise promise promise have you done
some like Wikipedian just in case the
call comes like I would actually be the
black widow story is true though the
reason why Emily Blunt is in our black
widow dying on war Mir here is because
she had a scheduling conflict with Iron
Man 2 and couldn't do it
that's how Scarlett Johansson wound up
becoming the black widow of the MCU in
the rest was history
but since they both almost became Marvel
characters they've only become bigger
and bigger stars so of course Marvel
still wants them in the MCU regardless
of what the characters might wind up
being they've already started setting up
the Fantastic Four characters with
Easter eggs in spider-man far from home
and in the post-credits scene so number
two the first big Fantastic Four Easter
Egg is actually the New Avengers Tower
remember that a mystery buyer got it
from Iron Man
during spider-man homecoming in the new
construction on it was still underway
during spider-man far from home
in that ending scene when spider-man
swings down to land in front of it on
the street you can see a New York City
Construction sign in front of the
building that says we are so excited to
show you what comes next with the
numbers 1 2 3 in a blank we're the
number 4 should be not only is that a
Marvel phase 4 Easter Egg like Marvel
can't wait to show us the new movies
that are coming next in Marvel phase 4
but it's also a fantastic for Easter Egg
the different colors of the numbers
correspond to each of the Fantastic
Four's powers and people ask about the
Invisible Woman what about her the joke
being that the missing number 4 is a
reference to her invisibility powers
also the street corner that spider-man
and MJ are standing on here at East 41st
and library way is just a block or two
away from where the Baxter building is
in Marvel Comics I also kind of think
it's more realistic to think that the
Avengers Tower would become the new
Baxter building because the only other
big option would be like Oscorp for
sinister six spider-man purposes and
even though Marvel just resigned their
sharing deal with spider-man they aren't
always guaranteed to have spider-man in
future movies so they probably don't
want to risk giving Sony the Avengers
tower and causing some story issues down
the road they own the Fantastic Four
characters one hundred percent in
turning it into the Baxter building
would just make it easier for them story
wise down the road this spider-man far
from home scene was also finished after
the Disney Fox buyout deal was completed
so legally they were allowed to
reference Fantastic Four stuff Kevin
Feige said that they had plans for a new
movie but as of them releasing this
scene they hadn't cast any actors yet
and probably didn't have a finished
script but that was a year ago this is
now in John Krasinski is really excited
to be in that Fantastic Four movie so
number one the other big easter egg is
the nick fury spider-man far from home
post credits scene on the now confirm
sword Space Station from the comics
thank you very much Wanda vision for
that we'll get our first look at that
during the Wanda vision episodes but the
reason why they're doing the space
station and sword from the comics is
because of the Infinity Saga phase 1
phase 2 phase 3 were all about ground
level threats on earth shield was mostly
just concerned with stuff on planet
earth the whole idea of sword in the
comics is about dealing with cosmic
threats from space and beyond in the
multiverse it seems right now like
that's where a lot of future movie
villains are gonna come from like Doctor
Strange to multiverse of madness will
have a multiverse villain I just
mentioned Wanda vision setting up the
sword Space Station while Monica Rambeau
is actually going to be an agent of
sword during the Wanda vision episodes
all the Disney Plus series are going to
crossover with the movies so obviously
Monica Rambeau big Captain Marvel comic
book character is plugging a show up in
the next Captain Marvel movie which will
probably have something to do with
addressing a threat through the sword
Space Station we all know the Fantastic
Four famously got their powers when they
were caught in a cosmic storm in Earth's
orbit it would be the easiest thing in
the world to say that there are normal
scientists in the MCU working on the
sword Space Station
maybe there's a disaster the space
station gets hit by cosmic rays that
would be a really easy way to give them
their powers that make sense
so you can see that they're laying the
groundwork to introduce those characters
I know everyone is looking at the fan
art of Andrew Garfield as Johnny Storm
asking about that but I don't think that
he would come into the MCU doing a role
like that they'd probably go for someone
a little bit younger but I am hoping at
some point that he comes back for some
live-action spider-man into the
spider-verse because there's been all
this to be McGuire Easter egg talk
because now Sam Raimi is gonna be
directing Doctor Strange 2 so if you
hear any news about Andrew Garfield
coming back for anything like spider-man
into the spider burst or something like
that then I will totally do a video
about it but post all your theories in
the comments below do you think the
Fantastic Four characters will appear in
other people's movies first like
spider-man Civil War style or do you
think we'll see them for the first time
when they do the new Marvel Fantastic
Four reboot movie I'm working on a new
venom - spider-man video that I'll post
this weekend leave all your video
requests and big questions in the
comments below any other Fantastic Four
or marble phase four related stuff
everyone click here for my new Loki
trailer video in Easter eggs and click
here for my new Doctor Strange - Sam
Raimi video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome it's
Pizza time